el hombre adulto promedio bebe dos
litros de agua cuando se ejercita al
aire libre con una desviación estándar
de 0.7 litros usted está planeando un
viaje de un día completo en la
naturaleza para 50 hombres y llevará a
110 litros de agua cuál es la
probabilidad de que se queden sin agua
vamos a pensar que lo que está
ocurriendo aquí existe una distribución
de de cuántos litros de agua necesita
una persona promedio cuando se encuentra
activa al aire libre vamos a graficar
esto para que quede más claro cada
persona va a necesitar más de 0 litros
entonces aquí estoy dibujando los ejes
aquí pongo el cero y nos dicen que el
promedio de litros que se beben es decir
la media de la cantidad de agua que un
hombre necesita cuando está activo al
aire libre es de 2 litros y tiene una
desviación estándar de 0.7 litros aún no
sabemos si esta es una distribución
normal o no puede ser una distribución
muy extraña
y sabemos que todos necesitamos un poco
de agua pero a lo mejor algunos
necesitan muy muy poquito de agua
y muchas personas que necesitan el agua
en promedio de 2 litros
y otros pocos que beban muchísima
muchísima agua así que ésta podría ser
la distribución real y nuestra
desviación estándar va a estar a punto 7
litros de distancia así que tendríamos
si eso es un litro dos litros tres
litros
esa desviación estándar estaría aquí ese
es el promedio y aquí estaría de nuevo
nuestra división estándar
esta es la desviación estándar a la
derecha y a la izquierda
y sabemos que nuestra desviación
estándar es de 0.7 litros ese es el
promedio de cuánta agua necesita una
persona cuando está activa un hombre
cuando está activo lo interesante de
este problema es que estamos planeando
todo un día de actividades en la
naturaleza para 50 hombres y llevaremos
110 litros de agua cuál es la
probabilidad de que se nos acabe el agua
está probabilidad de que nos quedemos
sin agua lo vamos a escribir aquí la
probabilidad de quedarnos sin agua
es igual o es lo mismo que la
probabilidad de que usemos más de los
110 litros
y usar más
en nuestro día de actividad de célula
naturaleza
qué es lo mismo que la probabilidad
que si usamos más de 110 litros pues en
promedio tendríamos buenos 110 litros
entre 50 hombres los que dan para no
errarle vamos a sacar la calculadora y
esto va a ser
nuestro promedio va a ser si tenemos 110
litros entre 50 personas o 50 hombres va
a ser igual a 2.2 litros se nos acabaría
el agua siempre medio se consumen más de
2.2 litros de agua por persona
así que esto lo mismo que la
probabilidad de que el promedio en el
uso del agua o consumo del agua por
persona de nuestros 50 hombres
mayor
en efecto si es mayor que
2.2 litros 2.2 litros por hombre
lo que está pasando aquí es que estamos
tomando 50 hombres como muestra de la
población universal tenemos esta
información que no sabemos de dónde
salió pero nos dice que el hombre
promedio bebe 2 litros de agua y que la
desviación es esto
a lo mejor hicieron un gran estudio y
ese es el mejor estimado que encontraron
en donde ese es el promedio y esa es la
desviación estándar y estamos tomando la
muestra de 50 hombres y lo que
necesitamos encontrar es cuál es la
probabilidad de que la media de nuestro
muestreo vaya a ser mayor que 2.2 litros
y para eso tenemos que encontrar cuál es
la media de nuestra muestra o la
distribución de la media de nuestra
muestra y esto va a tener que ser una
distribución normal y sabemos algunas de
las propiedades de esta distribución
normal si tomamos muestras de digamos 50
hombres
esto va a ser y lo voy a escribir
y la distribución de muestreo
y distribución de muestreo de
de la media de la muestra
cuándo
n
o cuando el tamaño de nuestra muestra
es igual a 50 cuando el tamaño de
nuestra muestra es de 50 vamos a
encontrar cuál es la diferencia entre la
media de este estudio y la media de
nuestra muestra de 50 personas y
calcular su promedio del consumo de agua
ahora digamos que esta es la frecuencia
y estos son los diferentes valores
ahora el valor medio de esto lo voy a
escribir aquí la media de nuestra
distribución de muestreo esto es lo que
significa esta x con barrita nuestra
muestra va a ser igual si nosotros
hiciéramos estos millones de veces si
fuéramos a graficar todas las medias de
la media de muestreo mostraríamos que
esto esta distribución media sería la
distribución media de nuestra población
en realidad por lo que va a tener el
mismo valor y lo pongo en el mismo color
que esta población de acá igual a 2
litros así que seguimos centrados en 2
litros
pero lo genial de esto es que la
distribución de muestreo de esta muestra
es decir si tomamos 50 personas
encontramos su media y gráfica mos la
frecuencia esto va a ser una
distribución normal sin importar cuál
haya sido la forma de la distribución
esa tiene una desviación estándar
conocida por lo que no es normal
entonces quedamos que esta va a ser una
distribución normal y la desviación
estándar eso lo vimos en un vídeo
anterior la desviación estándar
o la varianza la varianza de nuestra
media de la muestra va a ser igual si
esa es la desviación estándar va a ser
la varianza de la población dividida
entre m si queremos la desviación
estándar de esta distribución de aquí
simplemente tenemos que sacar la raíz
cuadrada en ambos lados de esta igualdad
si sacamos la raíz cuadrada en ambos
lados tenemos la desviación estándar de
la media de la muestra que es igual a la
raíz cuadrada de lo que está aquí que es
la desviación estándar de la población
entre la raíz cuadrada de n conocemos el
valor de la desviación estándar que es
0.7 así que vamos a sustituir lo aquí
y la raíz cuadrada de nuestra muestra
que es 50 raíz cuadrada de 50 vamos a
sacar la calculadora para encontrar el
valor exacto así que escribimos punto 7
entre raíz cuadrada de 50
y tenemos punto 0 98
así que podemos redondear esto a 0.0 99
así que lo escribimos 0.0 99 y esta es
la desviación estándar de esto aquí
vamos a tener una desviación estándar
más pequeña por lo que esta distribución
va a lucir así sí aquí tenemos 3 litros
y acá tenemos un litro aquí vamos a
tener una desviación estándar más
pequeña así que vas a tener algo mucho
más angosto que esto
puede tratar de dibujar lo mejor
algo más o menos así
donde las divisiones estándar es casi
punto 1
casi una décima parte así que las
podemos dibujar más o menos por acá
tenemos nuestra distribución que es una
distribución normal y ahora vamos a
regresar a la pregunta original que
queremos responder
queremos conocer la probabilidad de que
nuestra muestra tenga un promedio que
sea mayor a 2.2 litros por hombre esta
es la distribución de todas las muestras
posibles así que para el promedio de 2.2
eso sería más o menos por acá así pues
lo que estamos preguntando en esencia es
que nos quedaríamos sin agua si nuestra
muestra cae dentro de esta área por lo
que tenemos que encontrar cuál es el
área bajo esta curva y para calcular
esto necesitamos encontrar cuántas
desviaciones estándares tenemos por
encima de la media que va a ser nuestro
puntaje z y que buscaremos en nuestra
tabla act para calcular cuál es el área
bajo esta curva nos interesa conocer
lo que está arriba del punto de 2.2
litros por hombres 2.2 litros 2.2 litros
está justo aquí es esto menos 2 nos
queda punto 2 por encima de la media por
encima de la media y si queremos verlo
en términos de la desviación estándar
vamos a dividir esto entre la desviación
estándar de esta distribución de acá y
eso ya lo calculamos la desviación
estándar
de esta distribución es 0.09 y vimos una
fórmula en donde tomamos este valor y le
restamos este otro y se divide entre la
desviación estándar y eso es lo que
estamos haciendo aquí queremos encontrar
cuántas divisiones estándares se
encuentran por encima de la media en la
que estamos así que tomamos este número
de acá y lo dividimos entre la
desviación estándar 0.0 99 y obtenemos
con nuestra calculadora y justamente
tengo el número exacto aquí así que
tenemos
este punto 2.2 entre este valor de acá
y aquí tenemos la respuesta anterior y
todo esto va a ser igual a 2 puntos 0 2
0 así que esto significa
que este valor
que esta probabilidad
es la misma probabilidad
de tener 2.02 de desviación estándar
y debo escribirla mejor así detener
una probabilidad vamos a escribir la
mejor en este lado donde hay más espacio
la probabilidad
de que la media de nuestra muestra
mayor
es decir que los 50 que seleccionamos si
tomáramos muestras de ellos y los
graficar amos tendríamos esta
distribución pero del grupo de 50 que
seleccionamos la probabilidad de
quedarnos sin agua es la misma que la
probabilidad de que la media de estas
personas sea mayor que 2.020 de las
desviaciones estándar
de las desviaciones estándar por encima
de la media por encima de la media de
esta distribución
y esto que va a ser bueno aquí tenemos
que buscar en nuestra tabla z éste 2.020
es el valor de cada punto 2 dividido
entre 0 puntos 0 99
vamos a hacer un resumen aquí
quedamos que tenemos que encontrar la
probabilidad de que esta muestra sea
mayor que el 2.020 de las desviaciones
estándar por encima de la media y como
les comentaba para calcular esto
necesitamos consultar nuestra tabla zeta
recordemos que la tabla zeta nos dice
cuál es el área que se encuentra por
debajo de ese valor así que la zeta de
2.02
qué es el valor con lo que estamos
trabajando ahorita 2.02 vamos a buscar
el primer dígito que tenemos 2.0 y el a
2.002 aquí está dos puntos 0 2 está por
acá aquí esta 2.0 y el siguiente dígito
está en esta columna punto 0 2 y aquí
está donde se intersectan vamos a
escribirlo aquí abajo tenemos que ser
muy cuidadosos aquí de escribir la
cantidad correcta 0.9 783 y no es este
valor de acá este valor en la tabla z
nos está dando el área de aquí que estoy
iluminando en rojo no desde dando la
probabilidad de que nuestro valor quede
por debajo de 2.02 de desviación
estándar por encima de la media nos está
dando este valor de aquí
para responder a nuestra pregunta para
encontrar esta probabilidad de acá
debemos restar esto a 1 ya que todo esto
es igual a 1 de nuevo tomamos nuestra
calculadora y ahora restamos 1 - punto 9
783 lo que nos da como resultado 0.02 17
así que esta parte de aquí en verde es
punto 0 21 7 y otra manera de decir esto
es que tenemos una probabilidad del 2.17
por ciento de quedarnos sin agua y con
esto terminamos el problema sólo déjenme
verificar que tengo la cantidad correcta
muy bien si es la probabilidad del 2.17
de quedarnos sin agua